you could have met the hit knit the hail
on the net what does that mean is that
some British I just I'm just saying
okay wait yes give me your body British
saying hi um you see anything morning
mate would you like a cup of tea
I don't know okay no I could have
probably system operation there anything
on the eyes the eyes looking at anything
oh it hungers the eyes are looking at
you I am trying to figure this way
what's this
nothing well this is uh you know Claire
didn't you know I did it but maybe you
should too
and we need to progress so just a little
bit all right
press B press v2 no clip oh wow yeah
boom
okay now hey look we got the password
Wow we did good job
wow thanks to me and my brilliant mind
yeah you do
that's great good job some reason I
can't move I can't no cuts into the
floor do you bid all right Danny yet see
someone had an accident on that floor
what's in here oh Jesus
here beware the cursed hallways I knew I
should even those laxatives Oh grody
some Cohen blog no don't go down that
road again I like eight other clothes if
somebody took that name I'm so mad yeah
I think they had it before I had it call
them was a disaster from the start you
know it okay got it
good job MA thank you oh you triggered
something oh there's there's all sorts
of guns in here there are jumping on you
got one Thunder ami let me add him I
thought I'd kill these guys let's eat
tough got him
I gotta mop and then there's a it's a
dumb down here huh okay
you getting this I'll follow you I am
going first meats on ye huh what do you
think oh nothing just being Old English
I don't know
oh whoa I think there's something behind
that I think so too
he calls quite the indents uh what is an
indent at then I think Oh
got it laughing [ __ ] damn it
look I finally had a revelation as to
what a vagina looks like luck is this um
I don't know how to break it to you but
that is not a vagina oh I could have
sworn in my science biology lesson no no
no I don't know what they teach you in
Britain land but that is definitely not
that
oh god amun so many of them we're gonna
die we're not gonna die stop being such
a [ __ ] all you died but I mean still
the point remains stop being a baby like
call me a baby I'm a baby you're kind of
a baby you're also dead you take that
back no all British people are big whiny
stinky baby some reason I couldn't you
have happy now yes I am very very happy
okay
boom okay where are you are you here yet
okay they're cheating your hell keeps
going up I don't trust them miles didn't
keep going up I didn't do anything
okay how do I get we got a key but I
don't know where it goes whoa what is
that
that's an eye well okay I'm out of ammo
for that one I'm happy
I got it it was a key but it was
nondescript it didn't have a color in it
maybe there's some other door through a
toilet you I don't understand what you
gotta hit by a car Oh
what car come from oh okay all right
look we got the key whoa God is there
anywhere else to go in there do I need
to come in oh why is there an old old
fly past no I have no idea oh just few
Passons gone through this window what
are you talking about what is this I saw
this before good job man I'm sure glad
we thought that puzzle whew that was a
close one they're a huge brand my bran
why I don't know you're a huge white
brain my bran what brain growing brain
where are you I'm in here okay I got the
key oh you got the key - Wow good job on
the Kate and I figured all the puzzles
these are pictures of as monkey as a
human there's like a cyborg uh-huh
amazing it's like a combination of the
two or you're an idiot and you don't
know what you're talking about
well I don't think Matthew nice touch my
children or I will haunt you forever huh
is there a baby somewhere here possibly
don't touch the kids I'm gonna touch the
kids all I feel good do not say that out
loud
you hear that yeah it's a nice lady
singing there's a lady okay I'll hold
them off okay pretty good I'm so jealous
right now I know this is a good is there
anything else in this room that we need
or do we get everything um when you kill
everything restful and I suppose hard to
kill yeah there we go
hi window we'd opened up Inc booyah yeah
it says I will devour your soul oh
that's not very nice I know you take
that back
yeah at least wait till the third date
to devour my soul she's going like
what's that first base yeah something
like that I don't know I don't know I
don't ask me these analogies of dating
and things I don't get them you don't
even know what a vagina looks like I saw
it earlier I showed out was not a vagina
hey the blue key card I'll sit back yeah
we actually got the real one this time
oh my goodness key card ah goddamn it we
got to walk all the way back then how's
any coffee
super heat superpower you know if you
ever do here every time week off you can
go through any like a solid object yeah
but just for as like a split second and
if you get caught inside something
you're dead once you start coughing then
your power like the activate
it is constantly coughing all the time I
wonder what my super-powered day huh I
don't know what you think that'd suit me
I don't know how about every time you
fart you're able to fly really fast okay
just like here just as you're zooming
through the sky it's beautiful in a way
there's just one giant cloud of gas I'm
flying through the clouds oh we have a
problem
oh my go just really shocked by your
Incredibles I know I'm just the best
aren't I yeah yeah what do we have yeah
this is very true this is actually
turning into a long one this might be
actually be a two-parter oh it could be
yeah we get mine's gonna be one paw yeah
if you were watching then it
mysteriously cut and this is the second
part misteriously uh uh hi just saying
I'm you know I'm like a tables guy and
um yeah that guy who don't know what
them female genitalia look alike we've
been through this too many times now I
won't talk about this anymore right no
neither will we talk about coal and blow
I can read this in a scary woman's voice
it's okay go ahead that's your fault
that's your scary woman voice broke into
my house [ __ ] off I don't need this go
away you killed my children you're going
to die that wasn't scary at all
I here is done um I I don't know what
you are on about there's some like red
kryptonite here got it what do we do
with it
the machine
well oh right
hi why did you go into that room why'd
you go into the room where they all work
oh really yeah I just I just wanted a
hug yeah well you're not getting from me
how I get all the vaginas pretty sure
you don't young man pretty sure you
don't have a sense I've been getting all
these muscles yeah what like what
muscles young man what don't you I've
been measuring them and they have
definitely gone I know what to do oh did
you see I got a rocket launcher oh nice
I still got this red stuff what do we do
with it um get out my face
Oh one kiss hey maybe this is a vagina
you never know no that's definitely I
don't have a giant looks like I showed
you a minute ago no that was not a
vagina you've been here I don't think
yeah no all right fun then all right
oh it's another red thingy I'll grab
that well you get that one I get this
one
awesome all right what are we doing whoa
oh
there okay she want to give me a kiss
yeah I did the three pieces of sacred
meat feed me wait a there's one to mean
it third one and my sacred wait for it
come on get my meat me me
Marquis master lies me how'd you like it
good meat huh fine if you want to
belittle me who's in the boys in the
wrong bathroom yeah we should have done
our thing in the other bathroom huh
destroy heart bits and open hell's doors
I thought I said poops it's not even
close to poops oh come on I was quite
far away on a link to that and you were
quite stupid away weren't you oh this
thing again my this this is bad Oh
destroy although he's spawned right back
down in oh hey we better go oh so it's
very ominous I have to say are these the
hard bits
oh no that's ammo he sees okay I'll
shoot them then my medium it's these
things I'm gonna shoot the thing is true
the Baggies a hard bed yeah I can't find
any of these there's one I found one
take that monster thief I got one I did
I got killed
oh Jesus Christ he's following me I'll
I'll balls Oh bollocks
Oh aah Oh much faster hey it's such
pretty cool I like that we getting all
these boss fights every time he plays
horror maps now yeah it's not bad I mean
peel the production quality on them
everything going up lately
how you shot me you didn't already Mach
I think he wants some of your sacred
mask jeez my sacred meats you say
doesn't everyone want a piece of my
sacred needs all right kill I already
killed the one down there we got to keep
going
just oh god he's spotted me I'm dead it
was nice knowing ya nice knowing you too
and by that I mean not at all good Jesus
I won't have any fun fictions we create
just by doing a video together
Oh storm Eddie you know I mean there's
no releasing one every time come on
I was almost killing it I'm gonna hit
this thing yeah yeah you hit it I think
that's the last one oh yeah yeah I like
slap me did you kill it uh uh wow I like
to me you're proud of whacking me too I
know that I know I always some ol wheat
meat for me to whack where again you
need some help back in that meat yeah
you come here and here never handed and
get double whack on this meat hey I need
an extra pair of hands to make this mean
way yeah oh yeah we did it yeah
Jesus yeah button what do I do about
that yeah I'm talking about baby
that yeah YUM that is a vagina this is a
vagina told you a fight is a vagina now
you have to kill the Shawnee good it I'm
sorry you Shawn no I did not ah I fall
into the pit well how stupid of you to
stop stop
so are you shooting the bigger crab
thing and I'll shoot the little guys
how's that okay how about we just all up
so you can kill the final boss if you
want we're both gonna have to kill it
anyway we're probably gonna die from the
one-minute so do it by only infinitely
spawning so I metella to shoot this guy
well we can't lose cuz we keep
respawning every time he dies what are
the problems of these paths they're not
boughs yeah it's pretty easy
oh well hey please please leave me alone
hit my mic once you tell him thank you
just call them ladies ladies nod and say
that ladies yamimash she's so popular
I'm pretty sure this is what a lady
looks like when do we need to kill the
red pillars you know I think I think
that's exactly what we're supposed to do
yeah kill the pillars first I've been in
the monsters a long time yeah that was
stupid of you you've been doing the same
thing John no I haven't you don't know
me I was watching you
no you weren't there's gonna be
problematic close eye on you markiplier
I don't think this I don't know we're
doing anything are we doing anything
think we are I just give it a bit of
time it's the final boss it's gonna have
low as a help you know it's gonna take a
while
do you say so maybe we're supposed to
shoot the middle they're going green
that's a good sign is it is it a good
sign
yes you're a while things go green then
you know you are a mean machine there
you go and then you eat some spleen and
Sin City
your characters doctor breathe easy and
you'll be clean yeah and I'll put some
beer in a steam Dynasty or in just an
esteem and then oh oh
I've seen this is ready doing anything
we hit this thing like 10 hours I think
we need to hit the setter thing I'm
pretty sure all right back to doing this
I guess I mean it twitches when we shoot
the center think that's the only thing
but look at it it's gotta hurt
right it's gotta be doing something I
can hear him shouting ow every time I
shoot thank you yeah Connie head out
listen oh yeah no I didn't hear that at
all that was you Yami mash you just said
out I don't sound anything like that
anything in there I don't know just I'm
just going in this compartment over here
I don't think there's anything in there
okay I'll have a shoot it that's good
it's going green hard
oh come on I'm trying to figure if we're
doing something wrong here because
nothing's really happening we just gotta
keep trying all we can do
I mean I don't think we're supposed to
hit the pillars just cuz the walls turn
green when we hit them though unless
we're supposed to shoot everybody you
seen the white thing yeah I'll shoot the
actual binding I don't think that's what
we're supposed to do either yeah it's
not doing anything he's not twitching
all right
oh oh sorry girls this music track is
royalty free it's probably not
whoo isn't that great oh oh is it it
well well done to me we did it oh good
good evil and killed yourself in the
programs Hey it is royalty-free yeah
five I don't kill me you don't know
false Barney er yeah
where'd you spawn oh you're right here
yeah all right that's one one all right
thank you so much for joining me on me
man hey problem hope you had fun I had a
good time
Haydn's do now thank you all so much for
watching and be sure to check out yami
masters channel for the other done that
we do thanks again yeah the good day
yeah
I think I okay go back